and staying across that story well let's
bring in our chief political
correspondent now John Craig who is in
Westminster for us there were no strike
action pause but what's the reaction
from the government John
well you've heard that statement from
Matthew there that uh there is uh uh
where the negotiations have been
completed and re and there's been a
final offer well how many times do we
hear an industrial disputes that it's
the the final offer from the employers
we shall see but you have to say
listening to that GMB statement uh that
they seem minded to recommend to their
members to accept the offer now that's
only one Union
um on the based on the experience of the
last few weeks the unite Union which is
one of the three unions representing
ambulance Crews has been more militant
if you like or more determined to pursue
a better deal and they're just bit it's
entirely possible you could have one
Union uh backing the deal and another
like unite for example not backing it uh
clearly uh the GMB is minded to accept
the offer the at one point a few weeks
ago the government was attempting at
what was described by union leaders as a
divide and Rule trying to buy off the
Royal College of Nursing traditionally
obviously much more moderate and less
militant Union than the others uh the
nurses as opposed to the ambulance Crews
um and as Matthew rightly says there's
still a pretty ugly dispute going on
involving the junior doctors whose
leaders claim that a junior doctor
starts on less money than a barista and
a coffee shop so there's not much
movement there and of course there's no
movement yet on teachers either and any
and various other disputes and not
obviously government employers but the
rail unions and indeed Royal Mail so
um this uh is certainly the government
will see this as a breakthrough now that
as to where the money is coming from
um there is nothing in there in the
documents or any of the small print that
we saw yesterday from the budget
earmarked for this and the chancellor
didn't mentioned these strikes but of
course what ministers have been very
concerned about in recent weeks of
course is that as they do try and push
for growth and the economic growth and
the chancellor called it a budget for
growth what is one of the things that
really holds back growth of course is
industrial actions
lack of a loss of productivity and of
course in the terms of the National
Health Service
um one of the prime ministers five Ames
is getting waiting lists down and health
bosses have been telling the government
uh till they're blue in the face the
employers how can we cut waiting lists
when our staff are on strike all the
time or many of them are on strike and
there has been a mood amongst NHS bosses
trusts employers organizations really
piling pressure on the government to
settle these disputes with first of all
the nurses and secondly the ambulance
Crews because it has been doing enormous
damage to the National or Health Service
and indeed really crippling the
government's attempts to get waiting
lists down so been massive pressure on
the chancellor and indeed Mr Barclay the
health secretary they clearly have made
an improved offer but whilst the GMB
seemed to be saying to their members we
think it's a good deal at this stage
um the we don't haven't heard that from
the other unions yet as far as I know
let me just double check
um here I have uh yeah now that's I
think this is a from this is the Royal
College of Nursing I think
yeah um
so
um
yeah in addition to a commitment from
the Royal College of Nursing the
government's agreed to new pay uh for
all nursing staff this looks like an
offer to nurses right
so the um are they say it appears to be
an offer to nurses as well
um a one-off payment for the current
Financial year between 1655 and 3 000
nearly 3 800
um and five percent for a next year so
there seems to be an improved offer to
nurses as well here so we are looking at
uh offers to two key groups of workers
in the National Health Service the
ambulance Crews and the nurses so um we
will see what the response is obviously
they are the GMB who've talked to uh in
terms of perhaps recommending to their
members to accept this uh of course it
has to go to a ballot that's probably
going to take a couple of weeks but
because the unions are pausing further
industrial action the government will be
hopeful that this is an end to these uh
very damaging disputes
um but um of course there are several
groups of workers and several trade
unions here so we shouldn't assume room
that these strikes are over yet and
there is a deal yet these offers have to
be put to the members and whilst they
are a big Improvement really on at one
point the government was talking about
three and a half percent
um that was going back towards the back
end of last year it's a big Improvement
but it's still nowhere near what the
unions have been asking for for example
the Royal College of Nursing started off
by asking for 19 then Pat Cullen a few
months ago said okay we might consider
half of that say 10 well this these
offers are still short of that so it is
entirely possible they may be rejected
but of course if the unions do recommend
it do recommend accepting them well that
will be a boost for the government and
could bring about the end of the these
that very damaging disputes so we await
uh some words perhaps from Mr Barclay
the health secretary who has been
holding talks over the last few days we
await also words from other other trade
unions involved here but just to recap
the GMB one of the major unions
representing ambulance workers ambulance
Crews does seem to be recommending that
it is the best offer they can expect to
get